the current state of Public Health is
horrific nearly 50% of adults have some
type of cardiovascular disease a third
of adults have metabolic syndrome 10% of
adults have type 2 diabetes 40% of
adults have pre-diabetes 30% of adults
have non-alcoholic fatty liver disease
if you were to go and and look at what
percentage of adults in America would be
what we would deem metabolically healthy
it's less than 7% of adults wow so these
are the numbers that we're up against
and these numbers they represent
individuals so this is why we're doing
the challenge and you know why I spend
so much time thinking about creating a a
plan that is evidence-based into
actionable and it will really shift the
needle and give people um confidence